la gardant notre misère nous acceptons
de nous reconnaître comme tel mais nous
imposons de lutter contre cela compte
cette situation parce que rien n'est
immuable
[Musique]
à
on
e
un capitaine de 34 ans grand admirateur
du colonel kadhafi a pris le pouvoir
dans un coup de force qui a fait cinq
morts et une quinzaine de blessés dont
six français
[Musique]
non
dans certains pays seulement 4% de la
population
réussi à nourrir toute une population de
plus de 200 millions d'habitants et même
à exporter et à constituer autour de la
culture une puissance économique n'est
pas normal qu ici à plus de 90% dans le
culte heures de cultivateurs de paysans
ne soyons pas encore en mesure de nous
autres suffit
[Musique]
pauvre tu as là ne voulait rien dire
pour personne en particulier pour nous
aucune abeille et c'est un nom qui ne
nous renvoie quand même passé
colonialiste par contre burkina faso est
un nom puiser dans le terroir même qui a
une signification dans notre langue qui
veut dire
patrie des hommes honnêtes
fini les mercedes aujourd'hui les
ministres roulant r5 et sans chauffeur
nous attendons que les pays riches
vis-à-vis des pays
moins riches que nous autres à une
attitude
moins paternaliste
nous ne payons pas nos bailleurs de
fonds ne mourront pas
soyons en sûr pas compte payant comics
avant de mourir
[Musique]
la face aux
c'est dans ce contexte monsieur françois
mitterrand que nous n'avons pas compris
comment des bandits comme jonas savimbi
des tueurs comme pieter botha ont eu le
droit de parcourir la france si belle et
si propre ils l'ont placé c'est un homme
un peu dérangeant président sankara un
nom c'est vrai il vous titille et voilà
il vous faut il pose des questions quoi
avec avec lui il n'est pas facile de
dormir en paix et là il a le tranchant
d'une belle jeunesse et le mérite de cet
état totalement des voix son peuple et
moi j'admire
ces qualités qui sont grandes mais il
tranche trop aussi va plus loin il faut
à mon avis un qui me permette de lui
parler du haut de ma l'expérience
on attrape il existe
nous devons donner à chaque femme un
emploi nous devons donner à chaque femme
le moins de gagner honnêtement et dimas
a dit le salaire de l'homme se partagent
actuellement avec sa femme et ses
enfants au détriment de la bière
[Musique]
ce que nous visons s'est
imposé la prise de conscience devant un
problème un fléau aussi grave que la
désertification pour ce trio nous
estimons que la responsabilité n'incombe
pas seulement à ces hommes et à ces
femmes qui vivent au burkina faso mais
également à tous ceux qui loin du sud
nous
provoquent de façon directe ou indirecte
des perturbations climatiques et
écologiques
[Musique]
si vous voulez je me retrouve un peu
comme un cycliste
qui campe une pente raide
qui a à gauche à droite des précipices
il est obligé de pédaler nous continue
de pédaler sinon il tombe
alors pour rester moi-même et promet
sentir moi mais je suis obligé de
continuer dans cette lancée là vous vous
sentez isolé en afrique mal compris en
tout cas mal compris mal aimé manu
[Musique]
vous avez des regrets
d'avoir perdu un ami bien sûr
[Musique]
on